una recta tiene una pendiente de 7 y
pasa por el punto menos 4 menos 11
cuál es la ecuación de esta recta en la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen y
bueno la forma pendiente ordenada al
origen es la siguiente y es igual a mx +
b donde m es la pendiente mientras que b
es donde interceptamos al eje de las 10
es decir ni ordenada al origen y bueno
lo que ya nos dicen es que tenemos una
pendiente de 7 por lo tanto m vale 7 y
entonces yo puedo modificar esta función
que tenemos aquí arriba sustituyendo a m
por el valor de 7 y que me va a quedar y
es igual a n pero en este caso ya me
vale 7 que multiplica a x + b y déjenme
hacer una x un poco más clara 7 x + b y
bueno no es toda la información que me
da el problema además el problema me da
otra pista me dice que pasamos por el
punto
4 - 11 esto no quiere decir que cuando x
vale menos 4 entonces y vale menos 11
entonces vale menos 11 es decir cuando x
en esta ecuación que tenemos aquí vale
menos 4 déjame ponerlo aquí x vale menos
4 entonces en esta ocasión ya vale menos
11 y esto nos da pie a que nos
preguntemos cuál es la b que nos hace
que se cumpla esta igualdad es decir
menos 11 es igual a 7 déjame ponerlo así
menos 11 es igual a 7 por equis que vale
menos 4 en ese punto más ven una vez tal
que satisfaga que cuando x valga menos 4
entonces ya tiene que valer menos 11 y
bueno de aquí lo único que hay que hacer
es despejar a ver me queda que menos 11
es igual a 7 x menos 4 que es menos 28
más b y bueno si de aquí agregó 28 de
ambos lados de la ecuación entonces que
me va a quedar déjenme escribirlo más 20
de este lado y más 28 también de este
lado del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
me queda menos 11 más 28 lo cual me da
17 y del lado derecho de la ecuación
estos dos se van y sirte sencillamente
me queda b por lo tanto déjenme
escribirlo por aquí que me vale 17 de
color verde de color verde no de color
amarillo creo que el día de hoy se me
están viendo los colores de es igual a
17 y bueno una vez que ya tengo ave
entonces puedo reescribir esta ecuación
que yo tengo aquí sustituyendo el valor
de 20 y me queda que james es igual a la
pendiente que era 7 es decir y es igual
a 7 x + b pero ve ya sé que vale 17
entonces más 17 que es igual a 7 x 17 y
ya está
esta es mi ecuación de mi recta que por
cierto podemos graficar si esta es mi
hija de las equis y este es mi eje de
las 10 aquí tengo un empleado que
anciano
yo sé que corta mi recta al eje de las
10 en el punto cero
17 por eso es muy importante bien aquí
estamos en el punto cero 17 lo único que
podemos hacer es sustituir aquí y ver
que cuando x vale 0 lleva el 17 y además
tenemos una pendiente de 7 es decir es
una pendiente creciente cuando x aumenta
en 1 y aumenta en 7 cuando x disminuyen
110 disminuye en 7 y ya tenemos estos
puntos y por lo tanto ahora podemos
graficar nuestra recta también pero lo
que hiciste es que tiene una pendiente
bastante grande y positiva por lo tanto
en mi recta es creciente y además que
nosotros sabemos que cuando x vale 0
lleva al día 17 es decir que pasamos por
este punto de aquí